in sundarth in 1853 a boy named Vincent
van Gogh is born
in 1880 at the age of 27 he decides to
become an artist
in his early years he taught himself to
draw and paint
but his style changed significantly
under the influence of impressionism
his career was was very short though
lasting between 1880 and only 1890.
quoting the Britannica biography on
Vincent van Gogh his palette at last
became colorful his vision less
traditional and his tonality is lighter
as may be seen it's one of his first
paintings of montemarth
by the summer of 1887 he was painting in
pure colors
uh using broken brushwork and at times
what's called pointillistic
finally by the beginning of 1888 one
goes post-impressionist style had
crystallized
the main painting technique associated
with Van Gogh is something called
impasto
where the paint is applied directly onto
the canvas and then spread around
it can even be mixed together
using other paints and sometimes your
very own fingers
very pretty
this gives the painting a thick
three-dimensional texture and the paint
itself is undiluted
a common practice is to work the paint
as little as possible because the more
you touch it and move with it the duller
and flatter it becomes with its stroke
the most famous example of this is
Starry Night 1889.
coding again the van Gogh experience had
the painting been done with flat paint
it would not have been the memorable
piece that it is
okay now I have taught you something
it's time for a quiz who's ready
lock the doors
is this a painting by Van Gogh give me
hands for those who think it's a
painting but Van Gogh nobody I have
taught you well
this is Adam on Brin skating on the
Frozen River even not even the same same
centuries still touched though still
Dutch
is this a painting by one go give me
some hands oh again I have taught you
very well
this is Vincent Vago farmhouse in
province 1888.
is this
a painting by Van Gogh
any hands
scattered hands all right aminia could
be early work could be like
inspired by other painter that's fine no
no though still touch
and but in the area so Jonathan bartolt
sound path
all right is this a van Gogh
oh
against scattered okay
yes this is Van Gogh you can see
the the brushwork on the head of the
crab is is disjointed if you think of it
that way crab on its back poor crab
1888.
okay good work
so hi
My Name is Oliver I'm a senior software
developer at turtleseack as
if you don't like this talk you can yell
at me on Twitter people seem to enjoy
doing that
so I work for a company called turtlesec
here in Norway we are a consultancy and
teaching training company
so again if you like our work please
hire us we do training as we did here at
this conference
good stuff so
this talk is titled learning Rush the
wrong way so the reason why I I named
the talk that way is yeah it is in part
about rust but is it part also about
learning so I hope you hope you will
enjoy
so what's wrong with knowing what you
know now
and not knowing what you don't know
until later right
I love I love quoting philosophers which
is Winnie the Pooh
good good stuff
so what's going on here
so yeah as you get my guess by the title
of the talk and the introduction this
yeah this isn't one of my normal talks
the structure itself is a bit of an
experiment on my end so let me know how
you think about it yes you will learn
some Rust it's kind of enough for me to
make a point but you will also learn
about learning the wrong way and uh yeah
the talk might have a point but we will
go places before we get there
everybody ready accepting
wonderful
wonderful
so
since the title was wrong ways to learn
rust let's do actual wrong ways to learn
rust right because let's let's be
literal here so at least we will have
that covered while skydiving
no
you will not learn rust while skydiving
even though this person might might be
having fun
um no I do not recommend learning rust
while scattering
um next example as an 18th century
Aristocrat this would be talking about
the paintings from the 18th century uh
no not for this
but for some reason they have Windows 11
on that laptop
so uh not recommended all right
um just to give a talk at the technical
conference now we can skip this one
all right
so what is rust let's begin with that so
it's a programming language that focuses
on performance safety and productivity
that's kind of their guiding Guiding
Light
it looks kind of like this so here I'm
defining a function here's the main
function
here I'm defining a variable how is the
visibility for those in the back
okay
good all right so I'm creating a
variable called float it is of f64 which
is the double from in other languages
the value of 42 you don't have to put an
F score
here I'm creating a variable so I'm
saying let the mid so it's a value
because in Rust it's const by default so
we have to say that the value is mutable
so you have to say let me
I can ask a question about the float no
parenthesis needed very good
I can then mutate the value mute
and then I can call Print line
exclamation point and similar formatting
style so the print line with an
exclamation point is from something
called a macro in the language so if you
see these different macros they are
defined in a little bit different way a
way of thinking of them is like what if
C macros had types and also looked more
like functions but anyway
yes good
so uh 2006 personal project by a Mozilla
employee called great and Hope
2009 turned into a mocilla sponsored
project
2011 we have the first bootstrap version
which is rust compiling rust
and then version 0.1 in 2012. so it is a
new language but it's again not that new
like when you think of new languages
that's like stuff coming out yesterday
so at least the idea has been around
since like 2006 789 that kind of thing
right
good
so more code examples here I have men
creating a value here's an integer i32
so the language talks a lot about
borrowing and what is alive and what is
not alive and what can you mess with
while you are programming so here I'm
going to
borrow my value into the function borrow
value all right so I have the little
reference value there I can borrow it
again that's fine and I can print out
those two those two values so notice
that I'm borrowing into the function but
I'm getting a value out of the function
so the function looks something like
this so here with the final function
power value again the type is on the end
it is the the reference of i32 and I'm
returning an i32 good
I can create a mutable value within it
which is a copy of the borrowed value I
can change it in some fun ways and then
returning a value from a function
usually looks like this which is like
the last expression the last statement
within the line and with no semicolon
you can do the return so for things like
early exits like if you do an if
something something you want to return
out you can do that that's fine
good
well what happens if I do this so here I
am borrowing the value mutably
so I want a mutable reference to the
value or smt plus plus just a reference
because the thing we had before is a
const reference
all right what happens then any hands
now since I've been training you on the
hands
doesn't work
does not work
so here's the main thing
uh we're looking at line 11 there
new value power value and we're sending
in reference types differ immutability
the Blue Line might not be visible it
can read it out arguments to this
function are incorrect we expected a
mutable reference so ref mu to 532 but
we found the regular reference
so this has to match
okay which is like one of the the early
walls you will hit with the language
good so if I have another main I have my
value and how much so my value is
mutable how much is not mutable
so here I am sending in my value into
the function as a mutable reference you
can now mute the mutate value is allowed
to change the the value and how much I'm
just sending it by reference by the way
I don't have to send it in as preference
I can send it in a copy but I'm just
showing you the referencing referencing
part of it
and then I can print out the my value
and it it would have changed so I take
value in as mutable at 32 by taking how
much as a reference to i32 I change the
value
we are happy this is fine I mean fine
not fine but but as a the language is
happy with you basically the sentence is
so what if I change this to this
so this is a thing in in C plus which is
the
like this is a problem people have and
and we have to learn like in what order
things are evaluated like oh it's from
the left from the right to the left for
the arguments and all these kinds of
things so here I'm sending in uh mutable
a mutable reference of my value and then
I'm also sending a reference to my value
but in within the function they are a
different variable but they're
referencing the same value from the
outside so again hence what's going to
happen
yes
compiler error that's right
so you are asking for
mutability from one variable you're
asking for a non-mutability from another
variable but it happens to be the same
variable
so think of the the single writer mostly
reader locks that we have where you
connect when you can have only have one
writer to a variable but you have many
readers so imagine a programming
language or every single variable is an
is an uh what's an msrv lock
not the actual lock but the language
feature so yeah an immutable borrow
occurs here while we have a mutable
borrow for the first argument
this this won't work
let's talk about baseball
who likes baseball yeah
more from American sport maybe so
hitting a baseball is a relatively
complicated skill
you need speed to recognize what kind of
ball is being thrown at you you need
Precision to hit the ball and strength
to make sure it goes as far as possible
in 2018 the batting average was 0.248
which means that the average baseball
player had a 24.8 chance to hit the ball
okay
this is not per ball thrown but for the
entire attempt how many balls are being
thrown at the person some of them can be
strikes some of them can be what's
called balls
so there is a bit more to it but that's
the general idea
you have a ball on the way
so Carl poly Mustangs are a baseball
team that represent the California
Polytechnic State University
the team was founded in
1948 and have competed in What's called
the Big West Conference since 1997 and
they even won it in 2014.
in 1994 the university published a paper
by Hall Dominic's and caravasos
Cavazos
called contextual inference effects with
skilled basketball
with skilled baseball players and the
references also down there if you're
looking at this later on
uh the study took a group of baseball
players and measured their batting
averages
the idea was then to give them extra
batting practices for six weeks
so the baseball study
they were split into three groups
one of the groups got thrown balls in a
structured order
15 first of them were fastballs the next
15 balls in the practice were curveballs
the next 15 or change ups and a change
up as I think a ball that starts out
looking like a fastball but becomes a
curveball or the other way around the
idea is that it changes halfway
they were always thrown in this order
and the players always knew what type of
ball was being thrown next
this is sometimes called blocked
practice where you split the exercise
into similarly structured blocks
okay
the second group got the same number of
basketball I keep saying basketballs
maybe I should change this no
they get a key same number of baseballs
but the order so it's still 45 but the
order was random so they had no idea
what ball was next maybe they knew the
last one but if they were counting but
anyway
uh and then there was a control group
who did not get any extra practice
okay
so let's look at the results
what do you think happened
think about what kind of kind of
practice this was
one group got they knew what they were
getting so I can know I can practice for
one of the balls
so I will then practice for that the
other group had no idea just a there's a
ball happening and then
yeah now the third group got nothing so
we have a control group okay
so after the six weeks there was another
test so we had to test the beginning six
weeks and then another test where they
got 45 random balls
and the control group improved by 6.2
percent I mean people are getting better
or there's some random variation in how
you're testing so you can ignore the six
percent or you can reduce the results by
six percent
okay
the block group which is do they know
what they're getting they improved by
24.8 percent it's pretty nice
where do you think the render group hit
any guessers around the block
the same
56.7 percent
what
they don't know what they're practicing
for they get some stuff
and
it's like they practiced for twice a
month of time then the block group
what's going on
so this is weird
so some might say shouldn't the blocked
practice have helped more because in the
random practice you don't know what
you're practicing for
you have no way to prepare any sort of
mental model or muscle memory for the
throws that are coming
so we'll get into this a bit later
so what's going on here
I wanted to learn rust the programming
language not the the chemical process
I had the idea that I am a programmer
right
I have certain skills
I had some experience with programming I
think
those skills should transfer
learning another language like really
learning it should be easy
because I know C plus I know C I know
JavaScript for for crying out loud so so
doing the next one should be easy right
so
this is not a jab at the idea that rust
is difficult
because I don't I don't think that
matters that's not the point here
this is a jab at my hubris so if you
want to do a job at my hubris you can do
that
enjoy it so what I found that
I actually didn't learn that much of
rust
until I really sat down and I really
sunk my teeth into it
doing a tutorial here or there doing a
video lecture no didn't help at all
why
so as a curious person I wanted to know
why so instead of learning more rust
I wanted to learn about why I wasn't
learning more rust I think this is
called Yak shaving for some people
but at least you will enjoy the fruits
of that labor so I sat down and I read
books and I studied papers like these
ones I wanted to know why
when you have a skill beforehand
it doesn't transfer that well or it's
not until you actually sit down and work
on it only then it actually works so
let's talk about Pokemon
okay okay I'm bust and rust so after
going through these exercises that cover
the basics of rust then I made I use
that exercise called rustlings to begin
with very good to recommend them I
started to look at my older project that
I had made in C plus
so with the idea that I would just
convert them over
I have a skill here I want to see how
this looks in the other language I can
compare and contrast very scientists
so and yeah this is a great technique if
you're doing this if you have an older
project if you know another language you
should convert stuff over so
now you have to take a Pokemon quiz no
the general idea the only thing you have
to know about Pokemon is that they are
of a certain type
there are probably thousands hundreds
whatever
um but they are of a certain type there
could be a fire Pokemon a water Pokemon
yada yada and if a fire Pokemon attacks
a grass Pokemon they do twice the amount
of damage if a an electric Pokemon
attacks a let's say a dark Pokemon which
is one of the types they do half damage
and for the the black squares they do no
damage that's the only thing you have to
know now you are a Pokemon Expert enjoy
so what this means is
so I made a project
I think now 10 years ago
that takes where every pixel on the grid
I'll show you a grid in a bit is a
Pokemon of a certain type it will look
around the grid look for other Pokemons
and then do an attack do some damage and
if the Pokemon you attacked dies and
let's say you are an electric Pokemon
they will then turn into an electric
Pokemon
it's kind of like this
happy how well the GIF looks in it
so this is the simple first version
and this is also I'm going to show you
the rush station later on but it will
look quite a bit different but I had a
different parameter for the GIF that I
had but yeah it looks pretty right
they're growing they're thinking yeah
Pokemons attacking so let's look at the
C plus code and yeah this is from 10
years ago so you can totally make fun of
me that's that's fine
so you have an x-coordinate which is the
the where you are on the X grid on the y
coordinate same grid size because it's a
one by one grid
uh the idea is that you have a an array
of array of Pokemon
you will then get the attacker which is
the first Pokemon you get a reference to
it
and then you find out who your weakest
neighbor is
so you take you create a position out of
your position
you have an out variable yes out
variable 10 years ago off the enemy
position you have a function called
weakest neighbor you take in your
position the enemy position and the list
of the Pokemon then you will get out the
weakest Pokemon around you
Let's uh you get the position for the
Pokemon let's then get that Pokemon
itself and then you fight
simple enough right where you are who is
the weakest get a reference to it fight
cool
this is the rush version
so in the restoration the colors are
correct uh so yellow is lightning the
the purple one is is dark I think I
don't know the other greenish grass
maybe it's very pretty
I like it yeah it has other parameters I
think it's running faster so these are
more Generations than the other one
okay so let's Implement that in rest
so a Pokemon is you have certain health
and you could do a certain amount of
damage I think in the tests I had they
all had the same damage but then you had
the multiplier but it's nice to have
like a variable for it so when you want
to implement functions onto a class in
rust or Stockton rust they are separated
out you have the struct and then you
have the implementation for the struct
so this is a what we might think of as a
static function so this is to new uh
create a new Pokemon it returns a type
of itself
so here we just create a Pokemon you
might think of this as an R value then I
return so remember that I'm returning it
doesn't have a semicolon so I'm actually
returning the Pokemon out from the
function so I'm just creating a Pokemon
and returning it and that's 10 health
and it does five damage
then I have a function so you can say
it's a function take damage it has a
mutable self so this is a non-const
function and the amount of damage that I
want to take and you look here I'm just
taking a reference of anything just the
value and yeah simple as this
simple as that I reduce the health
so a battle is then a container of
Pokemons so rust has container stuff
we have here Vector they work generally
similar as the vector that we have
so I want to implement the paddle in the
same way I have a static function to new
the battle for this example I'm only
going to have two Pokemons
so I'm not going to have the full grid
just so to simplify the code
so let's just say Pokemon new pokemon
new and I have a vector from Vector from
two Pokemons okay
and again I have a battle and I'm
returning the battle so now I have a
battle of of two Pokemons so let's fight
cool so because we when we're fighting
one of the health of one of the Pokemons
uh goes down so I want to mutate the
mutate the whatever's in the Pokemon
so this is a way of doing a loop if I
want the index for n and I dot dot self
so I can have some length so self
Pokemon length
so again same way I'm doing a zipper
plus since I was converting stuff over I
get a reference to the attacker
I get a mutable reference to the
defender
and I say fight
okay
sounds good
I have the rust teacher shaking his head
no this doesn't work
okay so this is another thing
so here we have Kenneth borrow self
Pokemons as mutable because it's also
borrowed as immutable there
what
so the the idea that I had in the C plus
version actually has a problem
because in one sense I'm having a a
non-mutable borrow to a value and I'm
having a mutable borrow to another value
which is something that c plus doesn't
care about
but here they're like no this is scary
this is dangerous don't do this
so how would you fix this right
well what do I actually need from the
attacker
I don't need the actual attacker I only
need the damage so the solution in this
case is we just get the damage
and then we do the attack we don't need
the actual we don't need the entire
structure
to do a combat when only one parameter
of a Pokemon actually matters
so here's the language and telling you
you're being silly you should rethink
this this is not uh you're not
programming in the wrong way the
language is saying please rethink this
all right so in the actual version
that's what we do we just take the
values we need out then we use them
cool
let's go back to paintings
right
beautiful paintings
so in 2008 an experiment was conducted
at the University of California
the goal of the research was to detect
the difference between two teaching
methods
Mast versus spaced
they were asked to study paintings
grouped by the artist
what's called Mast you get a bunch of
paintings by one artist
and then you have to have a quiz after
that
uh or they were interleaved by other
artists so you'd have artist a artist B
artist T and then mixed together
so each Mass
participant would get a set of paintings
by the same artist
and you would spend time looking at the
style the next painting since it's by
the same artist and look for
similarities
like you look at painting a by artist a
next painting by artist a like okay what
is a similar thing here like we did with
Van Gogh in the beginning
but the space participants would get a
mix of artists all over the place
okay
so
what they would then have to ask the
quiz was basically like we did in the
beginning is this a painting by artist a
is this by Van Gogh
in the actual test they used like
non-famous artists or like like they
wouldn't have starry night right they
would have just some some artist
so the results were counterintuitive
because the spaced version did better
always better
never like there isn't a variance here
so the people who did not get to focus
on Art one artist the next one the next
one
they did worse
oh sorry the yeah the people who who did
not get to do that they did better sorry
other way around my brain
but not only that yeah the space version
but the participants are not able to
study a single painter at a time and
focus on their Styles got a better
result
so
and even if the masked version did worse
they like that way
they were asked afterwards even after
they've known the results which one do
you like do you like to learn one
painter at a time to focus on the thing
or do you want it spread out and
randomly selected even if they knew the
results no they still like learning one
at a time
they did worse they didn't care
so
from quoting from the the test in
experiments 1A and two combined 85
percent of the participants did at least
well in the space condition as well as
the mass mass condition
but 83 of the participants rated the
mass condition as equally effective or
more effective than the space condition
it's not even slight difference like no
most people
wanted the one same artist
strange
looking back at our own inability to
foresee the benefits of spacing
perhaps we fell victim to the same
illusion that we have railed against so
these are the study uh
the testers bjorken Cornell
and this has been done over many years
so 94.99 and 2007 different types of
studies
namely the illusion that a sense of ease
and fluency
accompanies effective learning whereas a
sense of difficulty signifies
ineffective learning
in the case of the induction in case of
induction as many as other types of
learning spacing appears to be sometimes
if not always a desirable difficulty so
this is the word
desirable difficulties
this is 94.
and this is the concept that's used the
concept of huge here is the important
Point desirable difficulty
we don't want things to be hard just for
the sake of being hard
the next slide is not a better version
of this one
I can tell you that this is a a Caesar
Cipher of two
now go with the slide
it's not better
so these this is this this slide is more
difficult than this slide
that's not does not mean it's better so
the key concept is desirable difficulty
so
sorry man
so quoting Elizabeth Burke and Robert
Burke again about desirable difficulties
they trigger encoding and retrieval
processes that support learning
comprehension and remembering
so this is this is kind of my summary
for this practicing easy things is
fooling your brain and thinking that
you're doing well
okay
good
so empirical Studies have looked at the
different learning methods and
strategies that have a positive impact
on your learning
so spacing that we talked about before
also interleaving so spacing is like
spacing out the different types you have
interleaming is different kinds of
learning doing different methods of like
I want to learn in one style and then I
learn another style and
yeah
uh variation like learn different things
as well and also this thing generation
so what generation is at least for what
they were thinking is
you will be taught something and now you
have to create questions about the thing
that you learned
you will not be given questions you will
not be given material you have to form
your own thoughts about this thing which
sounds difficult which it is and that's
good
that's what generation is
so
there's even a study done
uh Karen boss 1978. so kids were
supposed to throw bean bags out of
Target
group a practice by throwing at a single
Target like these uh these things here
Group B practiced by throwing at many
targets either closer or further away
but never the same distance as group a
then a test was conducted to throw at
the same Target that group a used and
Group B did better
so here we have variation
practice different things
so let's go back to rest or any language
so what does exactly take to learn a new
programming language
so is it enough to watch a YouTube video
good
to read a blog post tutorial
to watch an hour-long conference talk
to sit down the program
more hands more odds no
but you need all of these and more
because mixed together over a long
period of time
so this is kind of the the key that I've
been seeing through through obsessing
about learning is watching a YouTube
video is one style of learning
all right and then reading a Blog poster
tutorial watching a talk doing a
programming like you are inter you're
interweaving everything that is
happening here different learning styles
and this also adds time
so this is the
what I've been seeing through all of the
studies is it takes time and different
things that you do and then at some
point yeah you will learn something but
it is difficult and that is good
not the brush this difficult maybe it is
but that's another point
so let's learn programming in 10 days
right
or 10 hours or 30 days so who has seen
the books have they become less common
right yeah learning learning Java in 30
days or whatever they're called
there's a there's a blog post by Peter
Norwick which he's very angry at these
books and rightly so
so yeah I don't think you'll learn
programming in 10 days
so remembering
so what I can see from the literature
yeah mixing up practice Styles
waiting between study session so now you
have an excuse right
I'm I'm not procrastinating I'm this is
the waiting period this is the
incubation period between the study
sessions uh don't cram that's another
thing they they've shown cramming has no
point they've been doing uh they've been
doing tests on students that
I don't have the example of uh some of
them had to really cram before a test
the others were not allowed to study
before the test and there was no
significant difference between them
there's even like the what's it called
the cue cards they would like really
learn through the cue cards and yeah
there's no difference so don't crap
so this is a
rewording of one of the quotes
difficulty remembering things and then
finding the right results strengthens
the memory
I told you something and then you had to
recall it again
an anecdotal evidence or anecdotal story
that I heard about something like this
is
the memories you have of when you were a
kid exist as pictures in your in your
parents house
because you go back and you look at the
pictures so you remember the time you
went to the theme park you remember the
time you you climbed that Hill
because you see it again and again over
time there are other memories but the
ones that are pictures in your past
house those are the ones you remember
so
um in 1950s and 60s the concept of
errorless learning was advocated by BF
Skinner yes that Skinner that you might
be thinking about
so the idea
was to give you the information and then
immediately a quiz so who remembers what
I was doing in the beginning of the talk
right
um
so we are fetching information straight
from the short-term memory
that was the big thing like if I if I
tell you something and immediately
quizzes you on it you won't fail the
quiz and then you are an expert
right
no
uh yeah the opposite had actually been
shown to be true
to quiz people later
so there was a case of
I think uh yeah there's another thing
I'm going to show you uh there's a case
of the
a class has been taught in multiple ways
where there was a bunch of quizzes
during the uh during the whole session
wow
not seminar during the whole year half a
year
where they were given a bunch of quizzes
along the way and there was no final
exam and then just degrades from that or
there was no quiz and one big final exam
at the end with everything but then they
tested the people again I think a year
later
and the people who had the one quiz at
the end still remembered more
than the people who just because that's
what you're doing you're I learned a
have a test on a I learned B have a test
on B then I don't have to think about it
but those who have to learn everything
and take a test on everything they had
to really sit and yeah remember remember
everything that was happening
so they were given kids a set of hard
puzzle like the anagram puzzles
um half of them were just said yeah it's
gonna be hard
difficulty is just a part of it and
that's okay don't worry about it
the other halves were asked to like
explain how they would solve a puzzle
like yeah you have to solve this tell me
how you're thinking about the problem
the first group did better
yeah
just saying like it's going to be hard
that's okay you're gonna fail something
that's fine just let's let's go through
this the other one we talk about like
how are you doing things or I'll give
you a little tip on how to solve these
puzzles no no it's it's fine to be hard
um there's
there is a festival of errors in I think
Paris from the 90s
where they're just celebrating that
we're going to fail
and and it's like a festival for school
kids and it's going to be okay and then
we're going to fail things and it's
going to be hard and yeah it's kind of
fun
so
a question I might throw out there is
n't this how we learn as programming
also over time
so blocking of the spacing so we might
think about a specific feature or we
might learn about a specific feature but
then like we don't learn about the
vector and then only use Vector for a
long time now we learned about vector
and then we learned about algorithms so
then you learn about I don't know
something else right
so we do this blocking version spacing
like we don't keep there's not a class
on vectors I don't think
uh variation we learn about different
programming languages programming
language Styles different libraries with
reading other people's code yeah all
these kinds of things
uh generation I mean we write our own
code we read code by others we form
questions about the code that needs to
be answered
so we are again not doing this but over
time
and quizzing
I mean I'd argue that code reviews are
quizzes that we take every day that is
the question is this block of code okay
so we take a bunch of quizzes
all right
are we on time
good
so
how are we learning Russ the wrong way
in the same way we're learning
everything the wrong way basically
by looking for the easy way out like I
did my hubris
uh and we also fall into the curse of
knowledge while teaching because I find
this easy to explain so it must be easy
for others as well
I know what subsumption is
so I can explain to you what subsumption
is right no that doesn't work
so what is the rusty key to all this I
like this one oh I was so happy when I
found this image
in a in a bask in this image right all
right good thank you it's going to take
time that's the key it's going to
require practice
it's going to feel difficult and that's
good
because not because rust itself is
difficult because that's how you get the
best results
I mean we as programmers are Min maxers
we think about like what's the best way
it's optimal way and I'm sorry but the
studies show that the best way is the
hard way
in a way
I mean it's not like learning Superfast
or CC right
yes so
now I'm gonna be mean to myself as well
unfortunately in this case there's
considerable evidence that in many
situations this strategy which is the
one hour lecture is rather poor
from 71. what have we what have we been
doing what are we doing here just go
home
a lecture May Inspire motivate and
inform but rarely fulfills the
principles for Effective learning
it's certainly inadequate for developing
high level skills 71.
oops
yeah students who study the topic and
then generate their own questions scored
an average of 14 higher than on a test
and students that use passive strategies
like studying the notes or rereading
classroom materials
creating questions researchers found not
only encourage students to think more
deeply about the topic but also
strengthen their ability to remember
what they were studying
yes
when Pablo casals the cellist was asked
why he continued to practice the cello
three hours a day at the age of 93.
he answered I'm beginning to notice some
improvements
and because
like I talked about the one hour lecture
is not good enough it's it's 15 minutes
until I think it should be safe right so
thank you
so form your own questions please
yes
what if you need so it needs to be
restructed reconstructed that the thing
that is going to do the the mutation the
value is not the same thing as the class
because the the key of the issue which I
think is more correct is because the
self is mutable that means that the the
vector is mutable and I'm asking for a
mutable value of the vector that means
that I'm asking for the whole Vector to
be in a I don't know mutable state
so take it out of the class because we
are we are asking
um
we're asking the class to be mutable
when we actually don't need it to be
mutable and that's that we only need
that one value to mean multiple
so
I can I can show you the actual watch
code it's it's on GitHub I can show the
actual Pokemon content it's a bit it's a
It's oddly structured but yeah we we
don't do the compact there that's
basically the case
any other formed questions I know it's
hard
yeah that was before here
have I found
the thing I I feel I still haven't
mastered is the the lifetime part where
you do the lifetime annotation
um I'm still in the in the area where
like I will just put the lifetime
annotations until it works which I don't
like
yeah
exactly which is which is the if you do
the rustling exercises that is what that
is is you have a compiler error and it
will tell you like fix fix the error in
file number one and then you fix the
error in final number one it will read
through the test and then it will say
fix the error in file number two and it
will go into file number two and read
about it and the first errors are like
semicolons missing or the if statements
is wrong but then it's like I think it's
like 40 50 exercises
but the and what I found from the
rustlings when I was doing those there
are no exercises about the lifetime
because you can do so much with the
language without even thinking about
that because a lot of the times if there
is I think it's if it's one argument
into the function
the compiler will do the lifetime thing
for you correctly because there's only
one way to do it I think
so yeah the whole lifetime thing is is
weird it actually I I found uh again the
language kind of guided me in the right
direction which was
I had I was doing some web stuff
where you can do right thrust and
compile to webassembly and then run that
and I wanted a
a call back to the JavaScript code and I
wanted the Callback to be a a Lambda
within rust
but the thing is that the lifetime of a
Lambda that is capturing variables
cannot be static or cannot be like
globally alive
which is kind of what is necessary if
you want to be callable from outside
because you always need to exist because
you never know when you're going to be
called
so in other languages I might just get a
function pointer and just hope that
works and probably 99 of the cases yeah
that works but
but actually like that doesn't work and
the language will say no to you there
you have one
scale of I think the entire rust
language is lava and it's a hello from
me two I'm going to be at rust Fest next
year and I'm sorry everyone visited my
life
where are you on this game
seventy percent towards the second one
I like rust it's fun
okay
thank you
so here's the thing about learning that
I
because I learned this way so this is
the path that I've learned so I
recommend learning wrong and then doing
a conference talk about it
in the same way that people sometimes
ask me like how did you learn simple
words I'm like yeah I went to University
for for four years and and studied there
for four years so you should also go to
universities for four years they're like
do you recommend this book like I've
never read it so I don't know
um
I do recommend the wrestling exercises
that I mentioned
um I do recommend uh doing things in in
smaller incremental steps I do recommend
uh moving projects you have like smaller
hobby projects over because there's a
lot of like walls you will hit along the
way uh and it will be hard
um also find like a good like worse
Community to chat with that bunch of
them on Twitter uh probably because a
lot of them migrated from super plus
but uh yeah
at least start there and then yeah time
yeah
anymore well-formed questions here
[Music]
yes yes
yeah because like an example I had with
uh with the Pokemon code like I was
doing in out variables I was like taking
references to like arrays and stuff like
yeah I have done smaller projects where
um I so there's a there's another
teaching idea that I've had is is to
create limitations for yourselves
and like an example is you can you can
write a small hobby project or do like a
small thing but every single variable
you have has to be a unique pointer
like all of them have to be unique
pointers
and that creates a bunch of problems but
that also teaches you a lot about unique
pointer
so I've done that kind of thing I
haven't taken my own older project and
like done a modern version of them uh
maybe I should yeah
yes
I
I think I've done that with typescript I
think I would describe my typescript
like initially when I learned it because
it was a like a an
What's called the serverless awf AWS
project with all sorts of like
everything was async in the code and
like it was very like it took me a long
while to get like used to how things
worked and how things looked and also
how to learn AWS at the same time and
how this whole you have to like upload
the lambdas up to the cloud and stuff so
so I've done that uh the main issue is I
guess it's hard which I think is why
like like last year I did a talk on
typescript because yeah I think I knew
it pretty well maybe that was the the
reason why I knew with the world
um but
yeah I think that's uh that's how I
learned that so if you can
you should try it because it is
difficult it is very very difficult and
I think it's
it will take a while for you to be to
feel productive and and for some people
that might feel uncomfortable
okay
then thank you